[Music]
welcome back everyone kovid19
set america's housing market on fire so
what can we expect this spring
i spoke with jared our local real estate
expert for the scoop
okay jared let's talk this crazy housing
market things are nuts right now
spring is typically the time where more
houses go on the market but what does it
look like for this spring
let me start with first we just simply
need inventory
as a home seller this will absolutely be
the
most sweetest spring you have ever seen
simply put we need inventory
homes are currently selling within hours
with multiple offers from buyers
offering cash over appraised values lack
of inventory is what's currently driving
our home values right now and so to kind
of help manage that
we just simply need more homes right so
sellers market but what about
buyers how can buyers kind of compete
here
my goodness so rates are also
contributing to this demand
and the competition is really fierce
right now uh we expect
rates to land uh around three and a half
percent by the end of the year but
in order to really help compete in
today's market we
at the palacios realty we have 14
different ways to help offers
stand out for our buyers i'll just give
you two quick suggestions
to help understand that first of all
hashtag who you work with matters right
work with the right lender work with the
right realtor
those can have a positive impact on the
seller's decision
specifically submit your offer include
the first page of the du
or the direct uh desktop underwriting
from the lender and what that does
it helps uh the the seller understand
your qualifications right
and then immediately after it's
submitted have your loan officer connect
with that listing agent to make sure
that they can vouch for your
ability to close and to get it closed
quickly secondly get personal
include a handwritten letter or better
yet a personalized video
where you can share your vision show
your excitement just try and connect
emotionally with the seller
because every what they're seeing is
just a paper or a spreadsheet
get past that try and get them connected
on the emotional level because it's like
their
their test drive right and if they can
get connected to be able to help a
family
we're human we all like to do that at
the end of the day right i've never
heard of that
i love that idea to get a handwritten or
a video oh my god
what a great idea well let's talk about
you know when people are trying to sell
their home should they do any kind of
remodeling or what improvements would
you say they should do really every home
is unique and different but
just keep in mind here's a couple things
to remember while vacant turnkey
properties that are fully remodeled they
are certainly setting
sales records right now you don't
necessarily need to go through that
entire
process just to be able to get top
dollar if you can make your home look
and feel like a model
and if it's properly staged with you
know super clean and professionally
presented
you can absolutely get that thumb stop
action
online and multiple offers in line
if you're ready to go all in 100 use a
professional
help you get it staged and we can get it
sell
uh sold excuse me the key presentation
is about uh
presentation and timing and we here over
at the five diamond group of palacios
realty
we're offering a free no obligation
consultation for anyone looking for that
answer
we have incentives worth over three
thousand dollars that include a home
warranty professional photography
virtual staging
the goal is to help maximize your
potential you can call us today and
we'll help you figure that out
keep it clean and get it staged jared
thank you so much for coming in and
sharing this information and um
good luck out there thank you so much
give palacios realty a call at 702-333
and right now you can take advantage of
their special offer just mention channel
8 for a
free one-year home warranty with home
purchase we'll be right